[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le grand
jt des territoires sur vos chaînes
locales et régionales et sur tv5 monde
voici les titres de l'actualité elles
sont les héroïnes de nos hôpitaux sous
le feu des projecteurs et de l'actualité
depuis un an
stressé et à bout de souffle les caméras
de via moselle tv ont pu rencontrer deux
jeunes infirmières sur leur lieu
d'activité
d'autres héros dans ce journal les
travailleurs du refuse de la tanière
près de chartres ce lieu accueille des
animaux sauvages qui ont été abandonnés
ou retraités du cirque notamment là-bas
lions éléphants et singes ils vivent des
jours heureux vous le verrez on le
croyait parti l'hiver et la neige sont
de retour ces derniers jours dans nos
montagnes pour le plus grand plaisir
bien sûr des chanceux présents sur place
parmi eux les adeptes du ski de fond
comme a pu le constater la chaîne via
vosges enfin nous vous raconterons dans
ce journal l' aventure d'un habitant de
béziers qui se prépare à parcourir six
mille kilomètres à pied pour la bonne
cause bien sûr entre le burundi et
l'egypte pour l'heure notre marcheur est
encore en pleine préparation vers je
vous le disais dans les titres cela fait
un an désormais que les soignants ont
pris de plein fouet la crise sanitaire
fatigue stress lassitude perdre deux
sens même ils subissent les conséquences
d'une épidémie ingérable et
particulièrement bien sûr les
infirmières en réanimation
or yanvalou journalistes pour vyas
moselle tv a pu suivre deux d'entre
elles dans leur quotidien regardez ce
reportage
du coup là on va on rend dans la chambre
d'un patient covit positif un an après
la première vague le quotidien de
clémence casa de valve n'a pas beaucoup
changé
le moko vide est dans toutes les bouches
dans sa tête en permanence
à 28 ans elle a été diplômée de son
école d'infirmières il est à peine deux
ans et demi et déjà la moitié de sa
carrière s'est déroulée sous l'ère kobe
de 19
et si elle a choisi d'intégrer les
équipes de réanimation
la lassitude est désormais bien
présentes entre confinement travail
harassant et peur de contaminer ses
proches les voix des gens comme ça et
des morts tous les jours et en fait on a
l'impression de voir que ça de rentrer
chez nous
et de continuer notre petite vie sauf
qu'en fait à côte on peut pas sortir il
va se vider la tête peut pas avoir de
jean tavé qu'on n'a pas du tout
d'exutoire au point que
parfois la jeune infirmière regrette son
choix de carrière c'est hyper
intéressant mais après si on baisse du
cac alors cet état
j'aurais choisi sérieuse c'est plus ou
moins ce qu'ont fait pincer du travail à
la chaîne
clément se souvient de ce chaos vécu par
les équipes de soignants au plus fort de
l'épidémie il ya un an de 24 lits
habitués à cette prise en charge la réa
et passer à plus de 40 d'autres services
de l'hôpital on devait également
accueillir des patients qu'aux vite pour
absorber l'affluence est une note centre
madame cyr fin de dialyse chronique en
fait qui a été
voilà ouvert en open space avec des
poissons de ranimation un tube et enfin
vraiment c'était fait perrin croyable et
si la tension dans le service de
réanimation forte l'hôpital de mercy
reste à un niveau élevé de prise en
charge de cas qu vide notamment à cause
du nombre de variantes croissant des cas
devenue la norme comme l'épidémie elle
même comme sa collègue la réanimation de
l'hôpital de mercier le premier poste de
julie phase on a 23 ans cette jeune
infirmière vite au rythme des animations
et des des cubis du centre aussi qu
logiquement c'est difficile parce que
ben on se dit qu'on a déjà vu beaucoup
de personnes mourir
malgré tout la jeune femme reste
positive j'ai toujours voulu faire ça
j'ai toujours voulu prendre soin des
autres et ben je leur ferai sans hésiter
ce qui fait tenir nous confie ses jeunes
infirmières c'est la solidarité entre
collègues
une équipe soudée qui permet de ne pas
flancher et parmi les personnes
impactées par la crise actuelle il y a
les plus jeunes bien sûr qu'ils doivent
faire face à davantage de précarité fini
pour eux les petits boulots des
initiatives fleurissent un peu partout
en france pour les soutenir
financièrement une grande enseigne à
vannes a lancé par exemple l'opération
21 repas à 21 euros
et pour montrer aux plus jeunes que l'on
peut cuisiner sans se ruiner
le chef étoilé olive et sam sont leur a
préparé un plat pour un euro seulement
au menu l'antique carottes oeuf poché
comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces images
de tébéo
la recette a l'air absolument
succulentes les étudiants qui
bénéficient aussi de petits prix pour se
meubler ou s'habiller
comme dans le sud ouest à bordeaux par
exemple grâce à l'association et tu
récupères et moyennant 3 euros
d'adhésion
les jeunes peuvent ainsi récupérer des
équipements nécessaires à la vie de tous
les jours et à des prix défiant toute
concurrence
ce sont des images qui nous ont été
envoyées par télé 7 la chaîne du groupe
sud ouest en gironde ils nous menacent
par intermittence le confinement ne
concerne pas que les hommes il concerne
aussi les chevaux une épidémie de
rhinopneumonie provenant d'espagne
frappe les centres équestres français
dans la loire vous allez le voir toutes
les compétitions sont ainsi annulés
jusqu'à la fin du mois
précision et reportage d'adrien
bletterie pour tl7 la télévision de la
loire c'est la semaine dernière que la
rhinopneumonie touchés les premiers
chevaux en france un virus très
contagieux et sa forme la plus grave se
traduit par des problèmes moteur et
neurologiques des troubles pouvant aller
jusqu'à causer la mort de l'animal la
suspension des compétitions
professionnelles est donc logique plus
les chevaux sont brassées à droite à
gauche et puis il ya des risques de
prolifération de la maladie donc c'est
normal que
c'est normal que la fédération a tout
les toutes les compétitions ça vient en
plus des problèmes qui le lie au co vide
et on avait au moins droit d des
compétitions pour les professionnels la
sahara toutes les compétitions jusqu'à
la fin du mois aucun cheval ne peut
rentrer dans l'écurie marine segura une
cavalière du centre équestre d'unieux
doit préparer des futures compétitions
internationales le sélectionneur de
l'équipe de france doit donc se déplacer
et en toussant chevaux sont donc confiné
ici dans cette écurie mais leur vie
n'est pas trop chambouler sa les impacts
pas vraiment ce que on continue à les
sortir avait travaillé comme comme s'il
y avait rien donc ça leur provoque pas
un gros changement pour les écuries
françaises attendent alors la
vaccination de tous leurs chevaux après
ça il faudra attendre quatre semaines le
temps que la dose administrée fasse
effet on reste dans le domaine des
animaux je vous emmène maintenant dans
un zoo pas comme les autres la tanière
est un zoo refuge situé près de chartres
qui recueille soigner protège des
animaux abandonnés issus de trafic ou
retraités du monde du cirque ou des
laboratoires de recherche
c'est un projet hors norme initiée par
patrick viola ce pour sauver ces animaux
abîmés par la vie et leur offrir une
retraite dans la dignité
regardez ce reportage de christophe
rigaud pour le grand journal des
territoires des éléphants des lions des
singes la tanière est un lieu unique en
europe
plus qu'un zoo c'est avant tout un
refuge pour des animaux abandonnés
blessés ou issus de trafics illégaux
c'est incroyable arche de noé installé
sur 14 hectares près de chartres est
l'oeuvre de patrick viola ce et de son
épouse parmi les 600 pensionnaires
accueillis par la tanière on trouve
aussi des animaux de cirque aux
histoires qu'à bosser comme le lion
dalle son frère avait attaqué le
dresseur donc à 820 mal finie et
je pense qu'il y avait un peu peur après
une voix ramener ici par contre c'est un
des rares son ancien dresseur qui vient
régulièrement le voir il aimer l'autre
jour pour son anniversaire et qui nous
appellent regardant voir la nouvelle à
l'origine du refuge
une rencontre entre patrick et paulo qui
décide de quitter le monde du cirque
avec ses sources et ses otaries depuis
la tanière offre une seconde vie à ces
animaux à l'eau à ces sources
ça serait une catastrophe il a eu tout
petit il a eu il y aller il a sauvé la
dernière la mère l'avait abandonné quand
ils sont nés c'est pour ça qu'elle a eu
raison s'ils voulaient pas des ours par
l'eau la tanière accueille également des
animaux de laboratoire comme ces singes
qui ont passé la plus grande partie de
leur vie en captivité pour des essais
cliniques des animaux qui sont tous
arrivés au refuge avec de lourdes
séquelles psychologiques
on l'a l'ado droixhe aux antidépresseurs
mutati ça s'arrange on a encore un ou
deux quand quelques traces de ces cas
elle d' une électrode là notamment juste
à côté on fait des grèves de boxer ça va
s'arranger c'est pas parce qu'il a ça
sera t-elle car plus qu'un refuge la
tanière est aussi un zoo qui se visite
d'abord pour faire fonctionner
économiquement la structure mais surtout
pour faire de la pédagogie qu'on
explique aux plus jeunes lorsque vous
rentrez dans la tête des enfants que
cannelle refus au tour ils ont ils ont
participé à travailler travailler des
moeurs et parkinson et que peut-être que
grâce à canal rue show l'an prochain en
vivre on a peu vu leur maladie que
profiteront un peu mieux dans
grands-parents ont dis pas que c'est
bien ou c'est pas bien on leur explique
ça avec la crise sanitaire la tanière
attend toujours de pouvoir rouvrir ses
portes au public
une situation délicate pour les finances
du refuge mais une aide d'urgence de
l'état doit être prochainement débloquer
une bouffée d'air indispensable pour la
tanière qui depuis 2019 a déjà sauvé
plus de mille animaux
il y aura un peu de magie de brocéliande
dans la nouvelle flèche de notre dame de
paris
un arbre vieux de 90 ans a été choisi
pour la charpente de la cathédrale
justin baro pour tvr à rennes s'est
rendu dans la forêt bretonne pour un
reportage
tout en hauteur
voir cet arbre vieux de 90 ans mesurant
15 mètres a été choisi pour la charpente
de ce monument célèbre détruit il y a
près de deux ans dans un incendie
s'était arrêtée sectionnée par un expert
forestier
donc monsieur depp de bagues lions cet
art a été sectionnée par rapport à sa
règle titude à sa qualité de bois aux
fonctions des cahiers des charges de la
charpente
en tout une vingtaine de chaînes breton
a été abattus ces dernières semaines à
l'image de celui ci à paimpont
l'association des experts forestiers en
charge du projet à une courte fenêtre
pour réaliser la collecte la contrainte
biologique qui nous a été imposée
c'était que avant la montée de l'acf
donc le démarrage de la végétation les
arv puisse être coupé pour ne pas être
trop gorgé d'eau donc effectivement la
montée de sève commençant avec le
changement de lune normalement à la
semaine prochaine il fallait se presser
pour puiser à battre ces chaînes dans
les bonnes conditions ces arbres ont été
récoltés à partir de dons de
propriétaires de domaines forestiers
privés la majorité viennent d'île et
vilaine dont 8
rien que dans la forêt de paimpont on a
des partenaires qui en apprenant voilà
ce projet d'éveil des partenaires
entrepreneurs forestiers qui travaillent
régulièrement sur la forêt nous ont
proposé de replanter 15 arbres aux
quinze petits chênes pour un chêne
abattu donc 100 vaches elles vont être
reboisées dans quelques jours l'arbre
sera conduit dans une scierie le tronc
devra sécher encore entre 12 et 18 mois
avant d'être transformé en poutre de
charpente voilà dans ce journal
l'économie en région à présent avec
michel picaud bonjour michel
aujourd'hui vous nous parler de la start
up et unef qui veut donner du sens à ses
activités
elle veut faire en quelque sorte un
business for good qui peut dans certains
cas sauver des vies grâce à leurs
ballons gonflables utile et intelligent
michel bonjean cyril bonjour à tous oui
je voulais vous présenter la start-up et
aux nefs qui a mis au point des ballons
intelligent gonflés à l'hélium et quand
je dis intelligence et que l'on peut
équiper ses ballons photovoltaïque et
autonome de caméras voire de relais
téléphonique
autrement dit malheureusement vous le
savez lors de catastrophes naturelles
comme des inondations
souvent le réseau de téléphonie mobile
ne résiste pas et les populations se
retrouvent alors coupé du monde
les secours ont aussi du mal à
travailler sans outil de communication
grâce à leurs ballons ils ont donc la
possibilité d'installer en relais
téléphoniques branché sur les panneaux
solaires souples également installer
eux-mêmes sur le ballon et donc ainsi de
rétablir les communications ces ballons
sont capables de surveiller de grands
sites industriels et de renforcer ainsi
le dispositif de sécurité
en limitant le personnel et le nombre de
caméras installées sa solution a aussi
été utilisé en australie pour une
mission d'observation de la faune
sauvage ou encore sur l'île de la
réunion pour observer les oiseaux dans
un milieu difficile d'accès les deux
jeunes fondateurs julie d'hôtel et
cédric tommy si on crée un business for
good
alliant performances économiques ayant
un impact positif sur la planète et les
humains et ces deux ambassadeurs actifs
souhaitent désormais sensibiliser les
jeunes à l'entrepreneuriat engagé et à
utiliser leur savoir faire leurs outils
à disposition pour le bien commun
l'esprit entrepreunarial est en train de
changer dans ce pays avec cette nouvelle
génération de dirigeants
merci mishapi coup on vous retrouve dans
un prochain jt des territoires vous avez
dû d'ailleurs vous aussi le constater
après un épisode de températures
printanières partout en france
l'hiver s'est réinvitée dans certaines
régions la neige est tombée en abondance
sur la plupart des massifs ces derniers
jours pour le plus grand plaisir des
fondeurs les fondeurs ce sont les
adeptes du ski de fond dont la pratique
a explosé cette saison
reportage à la bresse dans les vosges de
livia buchères et dan didier pour viavoo
rue sur place il y a une dizaine de
jours on se projetait plus facilement au
printemps et pourtant l'année jeu nous a
rappelé ce week-end que nous étions bien
encore en hiver elle tombée en abondance
ce dimanche du côté du domaine de la
bresse liche pas et qu'ils soient
novices ou expérimentés les skieurs de
fond avait bien prévu d'en profiter
on a regardé la météo ce week-end et on
a vu que kiné g
ici donc en a décidé jeudi de partir le
temps est revenue cécile top quoi en
profiter à fond pour cette semaine on
avait ranger les skis puis ressortir les
baskets de travail à divers niveaux
terminés apparemment il va neiger toute
la semaine donc si génial on va pouvoir
encore faire quelques petits exercices
pour se perfectionner ou actuellement si
certaines stations comme celle de la
bresse-hohneck avait annoncé il ya
quelques jours sur les réseaux sociaux
la fin de leur saison ce n'est pas le
cas ici oblige pas qui a tout de même
pensé à la fermeture de tel quand même
dans un coin de notre tête c'était en
fonction de là des conditions météo
puis donc l'a vu ce qu'ils annoncent
pour ses jours à venir jusqu'au week-end
prochain ça va être des supers
conditions pour ce qui est encore un
coucou un prolongement bienvenue pour
les skieurs qui profitent jusqu'au bout
de cette saison particulière avec des
stations qui ont dû s'adapter
la fermeture des remontées mécaniques
engendré un report de clientèle sur les
activités nordiques avec dédé une saison
exceptionnelle voire historique même à
des chiffres jamais atteints avec nous à
la bresse la 80 mille skieurs qui
sauront qu'ils sont venus bilan positif
donc pour le domaine nordique du leash
pas qui devrait si les conditions météo
le permettent
rester ouverts jusqu'au 21 mars premier
jour du printemps
ce dimanche ils étaient plus de 320 sur
les pistes du domaine preuve si besoin
que le ski zum a trouvé ses adeptes cet
hiver une image encore de nos montagnes
qui n'échappe pas comme vous le
constater sur ces images à la tendance
fripes les caméras de 8 mont blanc ont
pu se rendre dans cette nouvelle
boutique située à morzine et porté par
une jeune association la montagne verte
ce sont des images de nos confrères et
partenaires de 8 mont blanc jardiner
c'est bien connu c'est bon pour la santé
le printemps arrive et les provençaux
ont cruellement besoin de prendre l'air
en cette période qu vide et notamment
les citadins en manque de verdure bien
sûr et c'est pour combler ce manque que
l'association suric tacot met à
disposition des jardins partagés sur
l'île de la barthelasse
à deux pas du centre ville d'avignon une
opportunité qui ravit les habitants
écoutez les propos recueillis par le
journal la provence sur place nos
partenaires je viens à vélo quoi et à
vélo on est directement
comme si on était en ville et on est de
suite à la campagne quoi donc c'est
super agréable puis on rencontre des
gens vraiment sympas pour les enfants
pour prendre l'air pour renouer un peu
avec ça avec la terre ça fait du bien
quoi on reste dans le vert desjardins et
dans le sud toujours mais le sud-ouest
cette fois ci où la rédaction de la
dépêche a eu la chance de se rendre dans
l'une des fermes de la maison chanel
situé au pied du château de gaujac dans
les landes
on y cultive sur 40 hectares la fleur
fétiche de la marque de luxe la camélia
des images enivrante comme vous pouvez
le constater écoutez d'ailleurs à ce
propos jean thoby qu'est botaniste et
qui est à la base de cette belle
aventure
le partenariat avec la maison chanel
nous a permis d 1197 de mettre en lien
et bien que certains camélia avec des
procédés techniques extrêmement nouveau
et novateur extraire des molécules qu'on
ne pouvait pas extraire avant exalogic
l'ordinaire par ma connaissance qu'on
n'a pas nulle part ailleurs
cette proximité entre la culture et le
produit fini en un seul lieu
c'est un métier millénaire que nous
allons vous présenter maintenant dans ce
reportage qui a façonné le paysage de la
presqu'île de guérande en loire
atlantique où les marais salants sont
devenus la richesse de ce territoire
situé entre la loi l océan rencontre
tout de suite avec un paludier
passionnés c'est un métier méconnu et
pourtant historique
c'est un reportage d'anaïs de n'être
pour nos partenaires de télénantes sur
place regarder avant la saline nicolas à
une vie normale de celles qui vous
filent entre les doigts où tout va vite
puis il a rencontré les marées et le sel
alors ce qui me plaît basse et déjà le
calme oui on est on est là on est pour
soi et puis les bandes l'accord avec la
nature il faut être clair tout ça ça
l'air naturel
on a l'air d'être en pleine nature mais
c'est pas vrai du tout c'est entièrement
construit
et donc ça prouve bien que nous les
humains sommes capables de faire des
trucs en accord avec la nature fait
mille ans que ça existe comme ça et nous
on est juste là pour l'entretien pour
pour améliorer si on peut mais lors des
toutes petites choses parce que il ya
mille ans que les gens améliore alors
maintenant il est plus grand chose à
améliorer
à quelques mètres de la saline se dresse
la salorge imposant monstre de bois où
se cache le travail de toute une année
c'est du sel de 2019 ce qu'on stocke
toujours au moins au moins une année de
stockage pour que le sel c'est good bien
aussi sortir etc te ment de l'os et du
sel naturel
nicolas n'est pas de ces agriculteurs
taiseux parfois il accueille des groupes
scolaires pour rompre cette solitude du
paludier en ce moment deux acolytes
poilus 8e compagnie sasha ces souris sur
tout alors plutôt que de faire du
piégeage chimiques comme on fait moi du
piégeage naturel à la force des chats de
la loire atlantique à la martinique
maintenant dans ce grand jt des
territoires avec un retour sur un défi
relevé à l'occasion de la journée
internationale pour les droits des
femmes
24 femmes du lycée professionnel de
croix rivail à ducos ont pris la barre
d'une yole ronde une yole vous allez le
voir c'est un bateau une discipline
encore trop souvent considéré comme
masculine
ces femmes déterminées à casser les
idées reçues ont profité de ce moment
pour montrer tout leur savoir faire
propos recueillis par via atv martinique
nos confrères et partenaires sur place
moins bon en ce moment compte que on a
le truc et on est capable et on s'y
maintient on a envie de s'y donner de se
donner pardon à fond et leurs résultats
alain fail et là on est content voilà
toujours dans l'actualité ça fait assez
de bruit pour que vous entendiez parler
alors que les théâtres et salles de
spectacles sont toujours porte close
certains artistes arrivent tout de même
à jouer et à pratiquer leur art
notamment devant des classes d'élèves ou
bien devant des professionnels du monde
du spectacle des représentations
intimiste auquel très peu de personnes
sont autorisées à assister reportage
d'hélène galiana pour via le mans tv qui
a pu elle y assister
l'image est devenue rare du public dans
une salle de spectacle face à des
professionnels du monde de la culture
bertrand cauchois présente sa dernière
réalisation mais heureusement le droit
de faire venir des professionnels donc
des programmateurs et des programmes at
risk qui viennent pour voir notre
travail est potentiellement l'acheter
pour les saisons prochaines
pour voir des spectacles il faut
retourner sur les bancs de l'école
des artistes se produisent devant des
élèves comme ici au lycée professionnel
jean rondeau de saint calais on voit à
travers les discussions que je peux
avoir avec eux en tout cas ce manque de
culture au delà de la crise sanitaire
aller et voilà il ya c'est pas assez
tout ce qu'on fait tout ce qui est fait
n'est jamais assez pour qu'ils puissent
s'ouvrir à d'autres
d'autres imaginaires la compagnie a pris
très tôt la décision d'annuler toutes
ses représentations jusqu'à fin avril
on a fait le travail deux ou trois fois
à chaque fois pour pouvoir remettre en
place des propositions c'est à dire mais
à chaque fois ces propositions sont
tombés à l'eau maintenant c'est vers là
près que se tournent les artistes et
caresse toujours l'ambition de retrouver
leur public
je ne me rappelle plus qu'ici il est
régulièrement sous les projecteurs il
s'agit du château de grousset à montfort
l'amaury dans les yvelines
il accueille très régulièrement des
tournages des missions de films il a été
construit 1815 et la bâtisse vient
d'être racheté par un repreneur qui
souhaite en faire un lieu culturel un
sujet de melody poquet pour la rédaction
de télé 78 dans les yvelines
[Musique]
trois tournages avec un point commun le
château de grousset l'édifice est
aujourd'hui vide de nombreux meubles
mais pour une bonne raison
deux ans et demi de travaux vont être
lancés le château vient de se trouver un
repreneur
il était donc racheter suite à un appel
d'offre qu'on a lancé qui a pris qui a
duré pendant un peu plus d'un an et donc
qui on a sélectionné donc une famille
française qui est amoureux de l'art donc
on a eu la chance de pouvoir construire
un vrai projet avec eux et donc ils sont
partis là je pense à partir la fin de
l'année on va partir sur des débuts de
travaux initialement fondée en 1815 avec
un premier bâtiment sur les terres de
chasse de louis xiv construit pour la
duchesse de chârost il est racheté en
1938 par charles de beistegui c'est un
château qui a une particularité c'est
très peu de gens savent que depuis 1950
jusque dans les années 70 dates de décès
de charles d'investiguer tout le café
society parisien venait faire la fête au
château de brousse c'est ça toujours été
privée jusqu'en l'an 2000 quand la
famille décès d'yves avant de châteaux
ses jambes des milieux qui va racheter
le château derrière et qui pendant dix
ans va en faire une restauration
il y a 6 ans des amoureux du château et
d'histoire se lance dans l'aventuré et
créé l'association patrimoine aventure
c'est nous qui avons entre guillemets
initie cette volonté de découvrir qui
était ce personnage charles de
l'esthétique et de faire découvrir l'
influence qui là encore aujourd'hui sur
l'architecturé le design est donc on a
créé une visite qui permet à chacun de
comprendre la folie de cet homme mais
surtout l' influence sur l'architecturé
le design
le château est classé monument
historique depuis 1993
à l'issue des travaux des artistes
seront accueillis à demeure on devrait
encore l'apercevoir dans de nombreux
longs métrages
le site accueille toujours des équipes
de tournage
voilà vous l'avez vu dans les titres
l'actualité tout à l'heure une belle et
courageuse aventure pour terminer ce
grand gîte est celle d'un biterrois qui
s'apprête à parcourir plus de 6000 km à
pied en longeant le nil du bureau ni
jusqu'en egypte c'est un véritable
parcours du combattant afin d'acheminer
d'ailleurs des dons de médicaments pour
la population sur place
claude cazes sc son nom s'envolera pour
son aventure en solitaire le 30 mars
prochain
pour l'heure il se prépare à toutes les
éventualités comme vous allez le voir
dans ce reportage de fatima cathy pour
la rédaction de via occitanie sur place
plus de 6000 km à pied en longeant le
nil à travers sept pays d'afrique
c'est le nouveau défi de claude cazes
afin d'acheminer des dons de médicaments
pour la population
une aventure que ce père de famille a
décidé de vivre seul en survie dans la
nature
alors forcément cela demande du travail
de recherche manger en chassant et
empêchant ou éviter les prédateurs et
les animaux a fait pas dans l'oreille
ils vont pas te manger tout cru aussi il
va rencontrer des animaux il pourra me
raconter ce qu'il a vu je pense que
c'est un super aventuriers parce que
quand même il ya et il n'y a pas tous
montiel courage de faire ça le biterrois
de 38 ans a puisé ce besoin de se
dépasser dans ses années à la marine
nationale et à la légion étrangère
il traînera un chariot de 50 kg remplies
de médicaments pour les ong locales
tout au long de son périple alors ils
s'entraînent depuis des mois plus on se
rajoutent en fait de contraintes et plus
on ad on aura des facilités en fait un
marché laventure débutera au burundi se
finir à 6 mois plus tard en egypte à
l'embouchure du nil le trentenaire
espère parcourir 37 km à pied par jour
je vais déjà me prouver à moi même que
effectivement ce type de défi c'est
possible pour une personne ordinaire
mais je veux surtout montré en fait aux
personnes qui sont autour de moi
communiqué ceux qui ne le sont pas que
tout est possible
ce qui fera que j'ai réussi c'est en
priorité que j'ai que j'ai mon sac vide
et donc que j'ai délivré tous les
médicaments en premier
en deuxième je dirais que je sois à lui
que je puisse aller jusqu'au bout de
cette expédition claude cazes s'envolera
pour son aventure en solitaire le 30
mars prochain et il prépare déjà sa
prochaine expédition l'antarctique en
voilà fin de cette édition du grand jt
des territoires merci à tous de l'avoir
suivi sur nos chaînes locales et
régionales et sur tv5 monde bien sûr on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
une nouvelle édition
bon courage à tous
[Musique]